our next guest uh hosts uh a tv show
from time to time here on peacock called
the rich eisen show
uh i am ryan lee filling in for rich
eisen right now we're gonna welcome him
from the east coast he's spent
the last two weeks covering the olympic
games
um what's up rich how are we doing hey
gents how are you
what's happening good we're good man
we're good thanks for the thanks for the
the opportunity again man i appreciate
it oh ryan
please all good man so what are you guys
talking about
well talk to me talk to me a little bit
about this uh
i'm interested so they got they got you
hosting this uh this highlight this
olympic highlight show called tokyo gold
this is just kind of like
is it a chance for you to kind of you
know pull back into your sports center
your sports center days
yeah yeah back in the day when i was
doing uh rose bowl highlights of ryan
lee
i'm back in the i'm hitting the way back
machine um
and now yeah like today was just
you know really like old school we came
on
right after a huge
event which was the women's uh soccer
team
taking on the netherlands and you know
we're in the studio getting ready for
the show
and uh highlights are coming in of
archery and
um and other things that were for
we're taking a look at but we've we all
had a pause we all had to watch
the women uh in extra time and then
lining up for penalty kicks in the first
ever
in the first knockout games of the
olympics and it's just
so intense and then you know you're
seeing everything and
watching it and then 40 minutes later
you're doing a highlight
with paperwork uh of the highlight which
is called a shot sheet where
the production staff puts together a
highlight and you write down
you know shot one is you know this goal
shot two and that just freezes it and
you know uh you're
getting it handed to you about three
minutes before you're on the air and
then you're doing the highlight
it's been a long time on that um but
it's like riding a bike
certainly when it's a big event and that
was just a dynamite match
a big game and it's just so great to
watch
big-time athletes who have been through
it before
just come through it you know like
you're sitting you're worried like
normally about a a penalty check but
when it's alex morgan and it's megan
rapino
it's just like they got that they got
you know obviously you never know but
it was great it was just awesome that
was the lead
djokovic lost today so there's no golden
slam
you would have been the first to do that
you know a grand slam plus the gold
medal in the olympics
all you need to do is win the gold medal
here and then the us open in a couple
weeks and
he got bounced um you know you
uh olympic golf um the swimming
um all of it it's just been awesome it's
been dynamite
that's great it's been great it's been
fun to watch um you
you certainly feel in your you look in
your element it's fun to
branch out there and do a little things
you've been with the nfl network and
doing your show here for so long uh
we've had some
some great guests on today there was a
lot of sporting news
but again what drives the car is the nfl
and
and carson wentz's injury today um it
was disclosed that it's going to be more
of an indefinite one
uh two rookie quarterbacks now getting
the reps for indianapolis they were
picked to be the team that uh that that
was
was gonna make a run for the super bowl
out of the south with ryan ballard and
frank reiching them getting their
quarterback what
what's been your take away from from
this news today well i guess we'll see
right i mean when it comes up when it's
a foot injury and it's one of those that
it's indefinite
that's got the uh you know it's got the
the
the french doctor's name liz frank
written all over it but you hope it's
not
you know and so you hope it's not
something like that that would be
the major huge blow the whole season up
type thing
for them and you know you have to sit
here and wonder
if there are other quarterbacks that are
sitting around
like would you if you are frank right to
say
the first thing i would do would call
the chicago bears and say let's have a
nick poultry
it would not be amazing if paul comes in
for an injured once and takes the cults
all the way to the super bowl
that's the first thing i thought of to
be honest with you right who's available
like who could be
that sam bradford type guy um
you know uh which would be fascinating
you know uh another
eagles quarterback that white somewhere
else who could be that guy
sitting around right now waiting for
opportunity because his team
does not really need him or require him
to be far
far up the top chart and the guys there
is it's false
but let's not get too far ahead of
ourselves let's see what indefinite
really means
but if indefinite turns into season
ender
literally that's the first call you
gotta make is to chicago
and say let's run it back with frank
reich and nick bowles and
and see how it goes which is clearly not
what the
cults want and the interesting thing is
this would hurt the eagles as well if
wentz went out for a long time
because that too would not turn into a
one yeah we were all just assuming that
the pick that
uh that they called scott was a
conditional
return into the one because once yeah
i guess we could be getting way ahead of
ourselves this could be the cart before
cult you know so we'll see how that goes
we had an interesting conversation with
steve weishard just a little uh while
ago around
uh what quarterback has the most
pressure on them and names like carson
wentz
was out there tua tungovaloa uh aaron
rodgers and
and i threw i threw one in there that i
thought was was very meaningful because
of how big the trade was uh
how good the team's been under jared
goff but i think matthew stafford has an
incredible amount of pressure on his
shoulders to make this team
a super bowl contender immediately
otherwise i don't necessarily know with
only two years on that contract left
if if anybody has any more pressure than
him going into the season
well i think the pressure is is is
people
that are you know usually a pressure
machine
someone like jared carr quarterbacks in
convert
that um you know need to make the most
of their opportunity in jail it hurts
because you're just looking at those
guys at that princess and saying this is
their one shot
um if they don't do it this year the
move is going to get made
for you know in terms of denver rogers
or
philadelphia i mean to sean watson
something like that could be done sooner
rather than later if
if uh if matters gets cleaned up and
cleared up in a way that you don't
you know currently see right now you
know i i i
that's a good one i i think the um
stafford
situation the camp acres getting hurt so
big
because brockman you know i've been
looking at you once every
day saying can't make this the guy that
i want
yeah you i know you really want him in
fantasy i know
yeah to the point where the point where
you know i think i stopped talking about
him because i didn't want anybody from
our league to catch up
oh great as if you know those guys don't
know what they're doing which they don't
um but anyway um i'm i'm i'm nervous
about that
about the running game and you know
um general henderson i guess is not even
going to see a touch of the preseason
now because they got to keep him
bubble wrap so their run game is
something that
to me was one of the reasons why i think
a huge
year um and that old line hopefully will
hold up because if the old line doesn't
hold up and the run game doesn't
materialize
well then that's going to be super
disappointing
for stafford that is now something i'm
looking at at the rams
i'm curious to see what happens with the
other quarterback situations
quarterbacks and you know will lance
um actually if he will go get the
opportunity the question is will he
actually
jimmy gene over the next couple of weeks
will you know
justin fields um show up and show
the training camp to the point where
dalton will be the backup will
you know will we see matt jones get the
um and obviously you know now that he's
in camp
and under the the um media
live tweeting stop um zach wilson
and brockman i did see your tweets
i was just reminding you to make sure
you have zach wilson muted because i
don't think you want to see what's going
on right now
oh come on come on really
tell me you saw the tebow video i did
not tell me what
oh my gosh honestly trevor okay i just
got off the olympic set so
situation they're working on they're
working on some red zone
trevor lawrence under immense pressure
from his defensive line
rolls to his left throws back across his
body
hits tebow in the back of the end zone
for a diving touchdown
tebow looks like a te1 heading into this
year
i love it you know what i because in in
much of my downtime
and there's lots of downtown and also
in the uh week beforehand you know like
me staring out uh a quarantine window
a hotel for ten straight today same
boston
skyline for ten straight days i do think
about what
what we can do as a group when we come
back together in august to start talking
about the nfl
and there is i'll do and give you a
little preview we're going to talk about
the
top five storylines that would be
awesome
if it happened well one of them
is tim tebow killing it at tight end
killing
killing it rich are you are you hanging
out of a window
right now on this call did the tornado
actually come and you're
you got sucked up in it i'm actually
standing on a street corner in
connecticut right now
with uh with earbuds in so i don't know
it's it's
you know what richard it's great it's
great it's not great ryan don't lie to
women
it's not great but tj's been a pessimist
all afternoon long so
no it's not that bad hey it just sounds
a little weird you're it's a little
windy sounds a little
windy you know why are you all alone
what uh you're
you're a fan of you're better or my best
yes you're much better much better are
you you're a fan of ted lasso right
the show yes i have not seen season two
yet okay
okay all right well i'm just going to
let you know and i don't want to spoil
anything but
you're going to be incredibly
disappointed uh with the writers
around uh episode 1 and what the
americans referred to as the yips or the
twisties
all right all right that's rich eisen
everybody he's joining us he's
he's uh working out of connecticut for
the olympics hosting the highlight show
tokyo gold check it out uh have a great
next week are you
in canton
are you going to be in canton next week
i am i'll be i'm going to be there
for two days two whole days of speeches
all right well i will uh oh uh my
god two days of speech let's get
together let's get together i'm gonna be
out there uh thursday through sunday so
uh let's say hi
so you're saying goodbye to me right now
the phone is that bad right now no you
actually
you actually sound great right now and
before you go rich did you catch any of
the nba draft what did you make
what did you make of the russell
westbrook trade oh god
how about russell westbrook and max
scherzer showing up in los angeles right
turner on the same night unbelievable
that
is unbelievable i i don't know what to
make of it like
you know it would be an amazing story if
the ucla's own comes back to the lakers
and
creates a big three but why the thing i
don't understand is
i love the spin i love the spin machine
[Music]
though the wizards trade him away
because they need to clear space to
build around
beale but wouldn't you build around beal
with russell westbrook
i mean what's up i think
you know and like if you're gonna build
a team everybody needs two
superstars and obviously the lakers
figure like the old ocean's 11 line you
need one more let's get one more like
they got one more and so
but you know everybody goes if you got
two you want three and that's
and so why would the wizards cough one
up unless
i don't know like what's up with russell
westbrook that he's now bouncing around
like a journeyman after 11 years at
oklahoma city like
three years in a row he's been traded
now his fourth team right
i mean you're you're with me here on the
rich and chris and i
are our similar thought i don't
necessarily know what this does for the
lakers either so it it
kind of i'm kind of dumbfounded by both
organizations and what their willingness
to
to get rid of one and to add a piece
look you know cruz cruz has been a guy
oh wow
a a gust of wind just came by and
knocked over two umbrellas and nearly
gored a poor old man
[Laughter]
thankfully that did not happen i've got
the weather here
and by the way it did stop traffic uh in
greenwich connecticut so
this traffic and weather together on
what the fives well you're going you're
going you're going back in the way
you're doing sportscenter highlights
um what were we talking about before i
knew we were talking about
russell westbrook yeah russell westbrook
but here's the deal like you know that
kuzma has been the guy
that that that that's been kind of like
the last man standing
for lebron to have on the team and
he was the guy that survived that whole
purge with new orleans
and now you know last year with the
bubble he was the guy that did it all
and this past year
you know was clearly his last but if you
if kuzma harold
kcp for russell westbrook i mean come on
that's a no-brainer
like that's of course you can do that so
what's happened yeah you know of course
you're gonna do that i'm just wondering
why the wizards
would say that we're building around our
star bradley beal
so we're going to trade like one of the
greatest triple double
players in the history of the nba
because we don't want to build around
our guy with him like my it just seems
to me that there's something
up with russ again um but he's coming
back to la and
we'll see what happens who gets the rock
at the end of the game
that'll be something that we'll enjoy
watching all season long and how about
scherzer
coming to the dodgers turner gets
healthy
it is insane what how how how did you
like the um
rizzo gallo double i was just gonna say
like are you shocked the yankees were
big buyers like that
by the way gallo rizzo like two great
wines
i love it great vineyard great yankee
vineyard village 2021 the gallows
with the gallo rizzo vineyard i'm so you
know
i don't know what it's going to do
they're far back i think the division's
out of reach
i think your red sox have it chris but
you know obviously
you get in the uh all you need to do is
get in the wild card win one game and
off you go
right of course i i don't know who's
going to pitch uh either pitching is
obviously very suspect still
but you know and gal is another one of
those guys
with the one of three results walk
strikeout home run
just add him to like four more other
guys like that in the lineup
rizzo is the fascinating one i i i find
that fascinating
he's just got like i think yankee fans
are going to love him
i feel for cubs fans that's all i'm
saying is that they lost rizzo but he's
still in pinstripes he straight him from
chicago to new york well they just they
just traded the cubs speaking of which
they just traded kimbrell to the white
sox
ryan's ryan's heart is breaking yes
[Laughter]
oh my god wow you look so sad right now
bro
well listen to this all right i get the
i get the tickets every year when they
come home
first game out the gate they throw the
four pitcher no hitter and i'm like oh
yeah this is going to be fun they
proceeded to lose 10 straight games
after that okay
now they've traded right i have all
these great jerseys my rizzo jersey my
at least chris bryant stiller my
schwarber jersey doesn't mean anything
anymore
my kimbrell jersey now you just told me
that yeah look everything you spend a
lot of money on that stuff
[Laughter]
you should just get plain jerseys bro
ryan sorry ryan
at least you're in our show chair so you
can get it off your chat
yeah that's what that's that's what it's
here for hey and hey rich just so you
know when you watch that
that trevor lawrence tebow clip no
you're just going to be
shocked greater response might be a
little different than brockman's
response to it
that's all they're saying i'm gonna let
you figure it out for yourself okay
again my preview of the segment one of
the segments will do when i get back
honestly tim tebow if he has
a major big time tight end season and is
a
factor and is somebody that you're
picking up in your fantasy league
because he's just
he's scoring and urban's got got some
magic with tebow because you know
you know even when he was poop in the
bed
you know there was always a some sort of
moment
where it would get weird the clouds
would deform differently
and honestly like if he can bring that
to the tight end position and start
playing some football
that's a top five story line in the nfl
that would be
mind-blowing it would be dynamite and as
ryan pointed out rich
he he wasn't out there with gardner
minshew or jake lewton whatever that
guy's name is
he was out there with trevor lawrence
he's with the ones
hey look if he keeps making plays like
that and lawrence keeps making plays
like that large might be named starter
[Laughter]
maybe
i think he's on a path i think trevor
lawrence is on a path to be named the
starter
but he's still got to earn it guys he's
got some traits he's got some physical
traits that are pretty good so what are
we
talking about rich thanks uh
thanks for taking time man and and uh
and giving us a throwback
um let's uh let's uh let's
let's have a coke in uh canton how about
that i'll see you soon all right buddy
all right brother take it easy
rich eisen uh from the rich eisen show
also from uh
peacock tv hosting uh the olympic
highlight show i like that he got
offended that we were trying to end it
early because his phone's
right he was not having that he was like
this is my show
meanwhile rich would be the first one
like you're gonna be the first one to be
like get him off like his phone sucks
this is the rich eisen show
it's that's the true pain you're trying
to get me off because of my phone yes
no no no i'm not going anywhere it was
bad i don't know i don't know
10 of the words you just said yeah yeah
no i have seven more minutes of takes
and ask me questions i know i host the
show every day
i know that the second guest usually
goes to about 11 40 pacific
time so let's uh you're cutting me off
at 11 34. what's going on here
what's happening hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here